you want to be settled down you said
marriage in 10 years
how has quarantine been on your
relationship lately
oh it's so great yeah you know uh i got
so lucky
with uh with with my ben well let's talk
about this movie
the babysitter killer queen i mean
surprise b comes back
do you feel like this sets things up for
a possible
third movie you know obviously in the
first one they killed us all off so
to really bring us back was was gonna be
hard i remember when they were talking
about it
and floating back a few different ideas
i think the way they did it was very
smart so they could make a number three
i mean they really could i i wouldn't
put it past anybody on that set to think
of some crazy
new thing and how it works you know i
i'm just like would they bring us
all back again like that would just be
you know like oh my goodness
what like would you would you do it
oh yeah i love working with this cast
i'm i'm very close to this cast in real
life
which is really nice i would love to to
work with them again
i was looking at your imdb ready signed
on and i feel like you have
so many projects in the works is there a
dream bucket role that you're
looking forward to doing right now i
love to do
a really good fighting movie really dark
you know
i'd love to with the action space more i
really love
uh you know this show that i've written
and
i really want you know to do more with
it
and i kind of just spend a lot of my
time writing to be honest i spend a lot
of time writing
what show are you are you writing the
show right now i've got my first two
uh episodes done and season arcs built
out
and whatnot i just uh i just made a
little writer's room in my house
which i'm really uh really stoked about
i officially have boards
everywhere and then i can write on what
is the show can you sort of explain like
what it's about
are you starring in it effects is though
it's just
such a dream home for me you know for so
many things that i work on
i don't i'm just trying to think of what
i could say about the show that doesn't
like the title itself really gives the
whole thing away but it's definitely
based in the industry
um it's very dark uh there's a lot of
uh young characters and parents and we
deal with the relationships between
those
um and all these characters really um
connect and are intertwined uh
throughout the whole series and each
episode you kind of just get a little
piece of that
and it shocks you and then that kind of
leads you into the next i'm just trying
to think what what else i can say
is it autobiographical at all is it
based on your own
no it's not it's definitely a it's
definitely narrative
but i think that in general if you're a
writer you pull from your life
experience
uh you know you pull from things you've
seen things you've heard
and you they kind of like fill you as a
person and then whatever you end up
writing
they end up working themselves in there
of course you are doing a lot you're
playing with a lot of different mediums
right now i mean movies tv
digital what does bella thorne look like
in a year from now in 10 years from now
like what does
the empire kind of look like yeah
the mobile right the life of a wannabe
mogul well
um you know definitely another book
there's got to be a
another book i'm working on it right now
my goodness 10 years like
uh you know
marriage happiness like taking a break
from thinking so hard hopefully and
running my empire spending more time
with
my family and you know friends i think
when you
when you work so much sometimes you find
out that you
kind of have like no like not a lot of
friends
you know and working so much and always
you know
working i think
you end up missing out on a lot of
really great things that of course later
in life you're like oh yeah your
birthday
man that day i was working you know
hopefully
in a good ten years i can kind of take
uh
take a good breather feel accomplished
and
feel good about myself but i'm surprised
like do you feel like a workaholic ever
like do you feel like your life is so
nonstop that you can't
just enjoy and and oh yeah
and really yeah i think i think we all
kind of feel that
in a in a bit of a way you know we we
all want to
you know work more uh the more we work
uh the harder we work the more we still
want to work like you know that feeling
of working kind of just never goes away
and i've been working since
literally a infant child and i think
it's really embedded in me to love work
to love
to work to kind of focus on nothing else
but work
everything to me seems like oh i could
make work out of that
um even you know uh
like painting my house and doing these
types of things where i'm like
constantly decorating and this
you know even sometimes i'm like i could
turn this into work i could diy
fans houses and their college dorms and
things like this i could make a show out
of this this would be so fun
i'm like you need to calm down girl you
also mentioned in there
like you want to be settled down you
said marriage in 10 years
how has quarantine been on your
relationship lately
oh it's so great yeah you know uh i got
so lucky
with uh with with my ben yeah he's um
you know he's he's he's really just just
just a perfect specimen
um and i honestly don't know how i got
so blessed with him
and i will say i love the foreigners
love um he is
sick um and i love constantly learning
about his life and you know
his culture and his everything like you
know just just so interesting
when you date someone that hasn't grown
up with the same moralistic values and
the same things as you
there's so much conversation to be had
so
we've really gotten to really know each
other and
uh the five the five months away from
each other was hard
um but uh i think we had like literally
i think
two fights during all of quarantine it
was pretty weird
you know and if you are having a bad day
you just
you feel much more like on the same page
as them
because i think everyone's had a lot of
bad days in quarantine
um so yeah i got very lucky
has he has he seen this new movie yet
yes yes
he has seen it um he definitely laughed
a lot of times um and you know
i think he likes looking at me walking
around in that costume